[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by cash we put in this
you know mr. green shut up to mr. green
for keep constantly keeping it fresh -
congratulations thing theme song and
it's always keeping it fresh it's always
keeping it fresh you always happen to do
congratulations cattle Rubik but it's
always stayed true to the good old mr.
green style so we hope you enjoyed the
do what and we're moving on to another
saw here is a new hit by Jeremy Renner
main attraction yeah I'm gonna be in
[ __ ] Houston we added a show we added
a show in Houston we added a show in San
Diego even though we don't like going to
San Diego but San Diego keeps liking
when we come to them and by we I mean me
so we're doing another show in San Diego
or as my mom would say San Diego because
she's absolutely [ __ ] insane in her
later years but it's all good so we got
some some some dates coming up and all
that [ __ ] come on a Hollywood California
and wiser a Hollywood California woman
I'm sorry well I will be in Hollywood
California but I mean Hollywood Florida
and why is there a Hollywood Florida
when there's a Hollywood California it's
so [ __ ] highly confusing there should
only be a Hollywood California or a
Hollywood Florida because Hollywood has
such a specific name here we are with
Jeremy Renner main attraction he's a
singer too here we go with one of the
Avengers main attraction by Jeremy
Renner Jeremy Renner looks like a most
regular guy in the world and that's why
people like him because he's so
accessible Jeremy Renner
main attraction Jeremy Renner is a
really good actor he's actually so good
but people don't realize because he's
got such a reg'lar face
here we go Jeremy Renner main our main
attraction they forgot about it ever
since that [ __ ] movie directed by
that girl Kurt rocker hurt her
rocker not hurt rocker because it's not
about [ __ ] grandma it's not about a
grandma with [ __ ] with with planters
fasciitis it's about and [ __ ] the war
so it's not hurt rocker it's Hurt Locker
here we go live jeremy renner made in
fact here we go he sings - for some
reason he's not just an Avenger he's not
just a good dramatic actor he also sings
songs you would listen to in a dentist
office here we go jeremy renner main
attraction he's getting definitely to
have songs about flying and flying so
high
pretty soon coming out with a song
that's fun I guarantee you jeremy renner
I'll have a song that's called flying
too high or something like that because
it would be in an elevator Jeremy Renner
Romanian med attraction bull's eye
[ __ ] there's a joke in there
somewhere I'm not gonna do it because
he's Hawkeye bullseye here we go Jeremy
Renner main attraction
he's got a regular face is so good um so
yes so uh but yes so what the [ __ ]
so what was I even doing san jeremy
renner dude killing it man he just made
a song he made some songs did you know
that he dude the fact let me just go let
me just start this by saying I
straight-up think Jeremy Renner is a
phenomenal actor and I love Jeremy
Renner and I think he's a great [ __ ]
he he seems like such a good guy he's a
great actor I loved him in the movies I
want to [ __ ] be his best friend I'm a
Jeremy Renner fan and the fact that he's
doing also rock music is hilarious dude
it's awesome his also the fact that he
can just make rock like he can do any
kind of music he can do any kind of
music she can make singer-songwriter
[ __ ] he could do stuff that's really
like cool like dark like tool he could
do anything he wants to do but he chose
straight-up rock oh that's so funny to
me dude with his [ __ ] short hair he
just chose rock and that's hilarious man
with his red face dude that makes me
laugh dude and he has a song called main
attraction
dude jeremy renner rips he's my favorite
actor now that he does rock music did
you know that if he comes to LA I'm
gonna go dude I'm gonna go to his show
as a fan I'm not asking for any extra
perks I'm paying for the ticket I'm
standing in the back dude it's gonna be
so dope I'm not hitting on my agent
sometimes I hate on my agent could you
get tickets for me to go to nope not
this time dude buying tickets for the
Jeremy Renner show standing in the back
any in popcorn dude his song first of
all of course the music video starts
with this [ __ ] the beeps you know
and he's walking into a [ __ ] he's got
a long coat the fact that it starts oh
dude the fact that it starts like this
[Laughter]
and he's walking in the desert coat oh
[ __ ] the [ __ ] way it starts oh dude
he's going like this he's walking down
this the road he's going like this I
thought today I have to do this I have
to talk about I have to do the podcast
and I can't burn bridges with jeremy
renner I gotta meet him though bro I I
gotta [ __ ] do this song rips if you
don't let me tell you something dude if
you don't like this song main attraction
you're a [ __ ] hater dude it's
designed to make you feel good I'm not
gonna play the whole thing cuz the
little flag it but it's so dope dude
what is he you know you know dude oh and
the comments dude not one comment not
about Avengers oh dude that's the best
it's got 4.3 million views it says this
is what Hawkeye did during those last
five years here's another one what about
Thor offworld dr. strange unavailable
Captain Marvel don't invoke her name
Hawkeye you wouldn't believe me if I
tell you
every time Hawkeye you wouldn't believe
it if I tell you dude just you know what
he should honestly be in the Hawkeye
outfit in this music video just ripping
[ __ ] fans with the [ __ ] what do
you call it
prowl and it's and then someone just
goes for and they just get ripped
through a [ __ ] thing with a Hawkeye
arrow and and they die and they
literally die and they die still rocking
out like with a [ __ ] with a with a
with an arrow like this and they're just
this is how they die they're doing this
and they go like this that would be the
best I'm sorry but that [ __ ] prow
look here we go 95 percent comments
Avengers Hawkeye through percentage
comments Spanish two percent comments
like the song that's what this guy who
tweeted or youtuber coming okay so let
me get this straight
this is the one I didn't get because let
me get this straight he's an actor
singer and makeup artist
Wow huh what about Thor offworld Captain
Marvel unavailable Hawkeye on tour
that's what this guy says oh man this
guy wrote this on camera he's killing it
with bowstrings off-camera he killing it
with guitar strings definitely a 14 year
old guy with some of these are great
though where's the one where there's
always the comment where that's like how
much yada yada do you want a rock jeremy
renner yes where's that one definitely i
dad that's the main youtube comment i
want to [ __ ] jump off a bridge when i
say it how much do you want to [ __ ]
rock jeremy renner yes or whatever it is
then I'll find I guarantee it's in here
here we go producer how much epicness do
you want in this song jeremy renner yes
dude you're
dork dude how much dorkiness do you want
in this comment yes that [ __ ] [ __ ] is
hilarious no no man oh man oh man oh man
oh man now no what's the [ __ ] I can't
play yeah yeah you're the star of the
show yeah oh you know he had the meteor
think I want to rock this is what Jim
Raynor did when he came into the [ __ ]
thing whatever whatever music [ __ ]
thing he's doing he comes in and he sits
down in that long coat with his [ __ ]
hair how it always is Jim Raynor he's so
interesting the only actor never
absolutely ever changed his hair no
matter what part he's doing dude and he
goes and he sits down and he [ __ ] and
they and they Universal BMG whatever the
[ __ ] it is you know whatever whatever
thing he goes and he sits down and he
walks in they walk by the way he walks
in like that he walks in like that with
his arms out and he has got the long
coat and then he sits in the chair and
they say so jeremy renner we hear you
want to do music we're all for it what
kind of music do you want to make and he
goes like he literally goes like this he
says he no he what he does is there's a
toothpick ins mouth because I'm so
[ __ ] bad-ass of course and he goes
like this and he said what's so funny
and they say you asked me what style of
music I'd like to make and the guy says
well yeah why is that funny and he says
because the answer is obvious and then
he puts on sunglasses and then takes
them off and says I want a rock and they
go like this yeah we knew it and then he
goes he does it like that and then gives
the valeted guy two dollars dude he
gives the guy he gives a valet dude
generator such a guy gives valet guy two
dollars and the guy thinks did he make
[ __ ] 40 million dollars on Hawkeye
and then he goes like this enjoy he goes
like this he literally goes he says hey
he goes like this any-any and it's so
racist is is Eduardo and the guy says oh
my god yes and he says hey any kids into
don't spend it all in one place and then
drives away and then and then way down
the road you think he you think but you
can't tell cuz he doesn't say it loud
enough he says I'm [ __ ] Hawkeye
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] I'll do a duet with him I'll do
a duet with him understand me [ __ ]
the goddamn Jeremy Renner's this [ __ ]
dude he gets no hate he's so good nobody
hates him he makes the killer ass
[ __ ] song and what there's another
song - oh he has another song called
heaven don't have a name ha said the
name before it didn't have a name heaven
don't have a name said heaven in the
title Chris doesn't have a name
didn't you I know I'm sorry never met
just it's all good just never mind just
oh I [ __ ] love it dude
because you're the star of the show man
I'm talking about me secretly always
always the same hair can't tell if I'm
35 or 50 Brown Oh
thanos loved his voice that's why he was
spared from the snap 14 summer says I
found out he by the way who found out
that Jeremy Renner who sings because of
the Jeep commercial yeah say white the
widest thing in the world is finding out
Jeremy Renner sings while watching a
Jeep commercial that's the widest thing
in the world because all white guys when
they saw that music video they went like
this oh [ __ ] that's what they did they
said Oh Jemmy under sinks that's the
whitest thing the only thing whiter is
liking an escape
that's the only thing whiter do it if
you were in an escape room if they shut
the thing and they were like if they
were if you were in an escape room and
they were like hey guys good luck
getting out more ha ha ha ha ha clink
and we got to get out we got one minute
another hold on put but bro it's just so
[ __ ] awesome that he sings main
attraction he's also got a song called
Nomad oh that's so cool
the fact that he could do any music and
he's like hey how are you [ __ ] crazy
I want a rock you know [ __ ] Jim
Raynor is the kind of guy who bites his
lower lip when he [ __ ] cuz he thinks
it's sexy dude and I do that too so
that's all good me and German or her
[ __ ] up our house we're pals were the
main attraction ah [ __ ] I want it I saw
him at the car wash once and he looked
like he was such a good dad Iron Man hey
kid we need you for a distraction
spider-man ok I'll do it Hawkeye hold my
bow oh god dude these dorks online hold
my bow um anyway [ __ ] he killed it
jeremy renner props to him he we should
win the Grammy Best New Artist hmm it's
on my babies mm-hmm
I'm excited because today I get to today
I get to go to visit my buddy who's
lived in Venice I had no idea but I
haven't seen him in since I went to NYU
for [ __ ] 9 months and I was friends
with him and I am friends with him we
kept in touch you know there's been a
few years that we haven't talked about
he's my buddy and he was in the business
school of Tisch in NYU and I get to go
see him for the first time in 18 years
and I get to go do that and
I'm really excited to it because I
really want to see him and it's this
[ __ ] and there were four of us you know
and why you there was me Tom Ted and Dan
and those are the whitest names of all
time and we all hung out and if it was
now I guarantee if it was now that we
hung out the four of us I'll tell you
right now we would be [ __ ] listening
to and I'll get my teeth done at the
dentist's office but we are chillin and
I haven't talked to Ted in a while I'm
sorry I haven't talked to Tom in a while
Ted I'm gonna go see in a little bit but
I'm very excited because I want to catch
up with him dude we used to laugh so
hard man they came to visit me in spring
break once and Ted [ __ ] threw up so
hard because he got so drunk cuz we went
to the House of Blues I don't even know
who the [ __ ] we want to go say but we
want to go to the House of Blues and he
started drinking way too much he drank
like some like fire like what do they
call him like mind erasers is what the
[ __ ] you know and then we've we drove
home and he threw the [ __ ] up out the
side of the car and I got so mad dude
it's so a guy named Ted to throw up at
the side of a car and we were all man
tom was laughing and Dan was laughing
and Dan used to laugh like this and Dan
was I'll let me tell you this first so
it becomes less sad later he [ __ ]
died it when I was 27 minus 20 he was 27
wives no seven we were same age 26 I
don't know he got a [ __ ] he got a
motorcycle accident do it and I [ __ ]
loved him and he was so funny he
provided us with so much [ __ ] laughs
dude goddamn he were provided us with so
many laughs cuz he basically he was the
kind of guy that just lived like he
wanted Goodfellas to be real he wanted
Goodfellas to be real life
Goodfellas in real life is how he wanted
it to be and he he wanted it to be and
this was the craziest thing too he was
we he was Irish
he was like Robert De Niro's character
he was Irish and he wanted to be Italian
so bad he would just be like he was the
kind of guy that like no you know I
don't like the way he took a look at me
what he's off he's on my list one time
he came out to me he said hey your buddy
Frank he's a carrier huh and I said what
he's a carrier I said what the [ __ ] does
he mean and Ted is like Ted the damn
things that he carries a gun dude and I
was like he just wants him to think that
he [ __ ] carrying Dan just wants us to
think that he thinks he's carrying his
gun cuz he thinks is Robert De Niro in
[ __ ] Goodfellas and he would eat so
much because he was trying to gain
muscle I just want to be the biggest he
could possibly be and we used to make
fun of him so badly like he would eat so
much but he would have to [ __ ] Vaughn
like he always got to meals always he'd
be like you know what let me get a
burger and then also let me get the
breakfast and we beat a diner at [ __ ]
Gramercy Park and he would just be
eating the [ __ ] and you'd be like I'll
be like man you're gonna you look bad
dude you're gonna look throw up he's
like no I need it cuz I'm buddy I'm
trying to beef up and he walk dude and
he had a poo pic in his mouth all the
time and he had like [ __ ] shoulders
that sloped down he look like a turtle
you know I mean and he [ __ ] walked so
me so don't like this you know how like
guys walk like this sometimes because
they think they're badass god I love
that [ __ ] man we would bust on
him so much he came to visit in in in a
in LA when we were on spring break when
wouldn't Ted throw up out the side
because of mind erasers and my family my
dad got a [ __ ] slam man remember
those slam man's that would have no arms
and you just beat the [ __ ] out of him
he'd box him they were just like they
came out and like I don't know maybe
1995 and you and and you would just box
him sparring Bob you know those kinds of
things and we had one of those slam did
that was the one we had the slam man
that won the yeah the down no right nope
the blue one yeah that would I dare ya
slam it and and and nobody ever used it
one of those things that you you know
you get and then you'd never use ever
you just feel like oh cool I'll [ __ ]
start its boxing the slamming and it
just stays in the garage next to your
car and Dan was like oh you gotta focus
slam in and and we would make fun of
them sod they would come home late at
night every time we came home from the
Spring Break hanging out and he would
just be like we'd be like where's Dan
dude and then we would go down in the
garage and turn the light on and he
would be [ __ ] hitting the slam man
just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] well
with the way [ __ ] looks at
dude and we would laugh so hard do it
with his toothpick in his mouth just
[ __ ] rocking the slam man killing it
just boxing uh yeah man
[ __ ] dude and then you were he literally
[ __ ] did and he went out on a
motorcycle which was like it's so darkly
funny it was like he was probably trying
to do a [ __ ] wheelie with a toothpick
in his mouth I love that kid dude I
[ __ ] miss him and so I'm gonna go see
our other buddy Ted and Tom was the guy
who he is Irish he's [ __ ] - I haven't
seen him in a bit I should hit him up
next time I go to New York they all live
in New York there's such business guys
you know I think Ted moved to [ __ ]
Poland and then moved by that's how
business you moved to [ __ ] Poland
dude you go to NYU and then move to
Poland s Business School dude oh [ __ ] s
a Business School to go from NYU to
Poland and then make millions and then
move to Venice a Sur Business School you
know all right
post mates when you need red wine at
4:00 p.m. sushi at 9:00 p.m. a breakfast
burrito at 8 a.m. and ibuprofen at 10
a.m.
post made it post mates is your personal
food delivery grocery delivery whatever
kind of delivery service all year round
anything you're craving post mates can
deliver to the largest on-demand network
in the US and offer delivery from all
the restaurants grocery and convenience
stores and traditional retailers you
could possibly want or need 24 hours a
day 365 days a year it's on babies plus
mates will bring you what you need
within the hour no more trips to the
store you don't even have to know where
the store is post which will deliver
anything to you
download the app for iOS or Android for
free it's awesome you browse local
restaurants you'll see it's so
self-explanatory I use it every single
day for a limited time post mates is
giving our listeners $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days to
start your free deliveries download the
app and use code Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 a free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post mates app and
if
you need any time you need it post made
it download post mates and save with
code Congrats
my bookie you know this we've talked
about it before look it's a new season
Antonio Brown is on the Raiders LaVon
Bellas with the Jets Odell Beckham is in
Cleveland the one thing that hasn't
changed where I'm putting my down my
money down on all the games
my bookie is the place to bet on
football every weekend my bookie has
better bonuses and more prop bets than
any other sports book period this year
they're hosting the first online
handicapping super contest first place
is guaranteed to win at least 100,000
and it costs only $100 to enter so what
are you doing
get off your butt you don't even need to
get off your butt do it on your butt all
you got to do is pick five NFL games
against the spread every week to climb
the leaderboard and score your share of
the huge cash prize pool
my bookie is always the right play you
bet you win they pay live in game
betting on any of every NFL game it's
great yeah up to up to $1,000 first
deposit bonus double your first deposit
use promo code Congrats to activate the
offer visit my bookie online today
that's my B oh okay ie and don't forget
to use the promo code Congrats CEO and
GRA
TS and when creating your account to
claim the bonus bet win get paid um so
yeah that's what's up my babies um yeah
man wow that's so funny that she [ __ ]
that he she that Dan wanted it to be
Goodfellas so bad he was like from
Florida and he wanted it to be like New
York New York you know he did I went to
NYU but he was like you wanted to be
like like he would have loved to like
gone to visit one time he told somebody
he was like from bed-stuy verson for no
reason which is love which was like I
don't know what it's like now but it was
like not the best area back then and he
was a gift bed-stuy you're like you're
from Florida that's what I think that's
what key where I came up with a thing
that nothing is more Jersey than living
in
and having a belly I was in Vegas and
would dude the most Vegas guy is a guy
who's like 55 and a little puffy and
pink and wearing like a tighter shirt
with jewelry and also like was at the
pool for 11 hours like that I saw that
guy and I was like that's so Vegas dude
I played the Mirage I love playing the
Mirage
I'll hung out with his Ed who you know
we're both fans of each other we've been
[ __ ] talking on Instagram a lot and
then he was like dude I'm gonna be in
Las Vegas can I come to your show and I
was like hell yeah and he was a count of
mine and I was like dude are you kidding
oh we're gonna go to each other's shows
and we did and we went and it was fun as
[ __ ] he played [ __ ] Nellie
so you know it's on and I was standing
on and the guy kept being like hey the
sparks are gonna come up but be careful
and I was like I got it you know but
anyway shout-out to all those guys they
were they really made it a lot of fun
Zed and his whole team you know his Ed's
German his [ __ ] I don't mean I you know
I already have a German friend Matthias
shuttle burger whatever the hell his
last name is and closin burger and so
since whatever it is and is it you know
I won't want to send him a picture of
his me and Zed and be like sorry bro you
got phased out I hung out with seven
Germans though man everybody was German
um it was cool somebody somebody kept
giving me the finger in the [ __ ]
crowd like just kept wanting me to look
over at his way and every time I kind of
glanced over he was just like maybe it
was a fan of Theo and um you know I
don't know maybe he just mad at the
world one time I drove by on the freeway
and there's guy was just holding his
middle finger out of the window for
everybody and my uncle said damn I guess
he's just mad at everybody and that's
how that's and that's the end of that
story but yeah I went to Las Vegas and I
went to San Jose dude those shows
Rep they were real fun they were real
fun they were really fun man I'm trying
to work my our I'm doing it it's like 54
minutes
it's like 54 minutes I'm trying to
figure out how to do 60 and I got a
whole nother chunk to work on after this
yeah boy keeps moving yeah boy keeps
moving forward you know you think comedy
stops just cuz I shoot another special
now I'm gonna shoot it in November in
Minnesota has it sold out yes kind of
that way yes
I'm not doing two of them yeah am I
gonna use the one that's probably better
and then cut in other ones when I
mistake on the first one yeah is it
gonna come out of Netflix yes are people
who are way too liberal gonna do the
Sukkot yes it's okay yes do they make
other people like it more because of
that
yes do they realize it no or is it can
they help themself maybe now who knows
um anyway what was I saying about that I
don't know
I remember I I got to fly and I was
hitting a lot of airports and [ __ ] and
where was I Oh in a casino in Vegas
casinos like do you know how much of a
[ __ ] raging [ __ ] you have to be to be
at a blackjack table getting a massage
dude what are you a [ __ ] Sultan this
[ __ ] white dude just hunched over
getting a massage like stay yeah you
know what hit me dude hey guy hey guy
sit up straight you're [ __ ] you know
just winning thousands of dollars
getting a massage you guys got [ __ ]
just a [ __ ] dude under him just suck
and he's not even gay but he's just like
yeah it's a service just under it a guy
in one of those [ __ ] terrible vests
that they wear pit-boss like would you
like a [ __ ] I did
I was there and I started betting um and
the pit boss came up to me and he was
like do you have a card and I was like
nah he's like you want one I'm like nah
nah nah I dude I don't like gamble he's
not fun
I want some money and then I was like
okay and then the dealer got 21 and I
was like this is [ __ ] I'm damned I am
out that I and then I that's when I saw
the guy get a massage get it I mean it
will do - how what kind of confidence do
you have to [ __ ] be playing blackjack
and getting a massage at the same time
from some chick named Dorothy or Dottie
but yeah like how about this man this is
where you get massages at massage places
okay you you see people at the [ __ ]
mall in like Jersey or some [ __ ] or the
Glendale Galleria it's always Asian
dudes just like want a massage and
you're like what dude we're outside Hot
Topic [ __ ] yeah you want to relax I'm
at the mall what are you talking about
who gets an Orange Julius and is like I
gotta go to the [ __ ] Apple store but
you know what dude that Korean probably
named George what gives a good massage
nothing's more Korean than being named
George in America yeah and so yeah like
what are you doing get a massage at a
massage place or get a girlfriend or a
boyfriend you know who gets massages at
the [ __ ] mall for real
jeremy renner and also gets massages a
blackjack you know what your and her
does for sure when it goes to Las Vegas
he goes and he bets and he literally
sits at the table and lets the house win
for a bunch for a long time for like I'm
talking to 2 hours and 15 minutes he
lets the house win and he's losing money
dude I'm talking about parts of his
paycheck okay and then he says well I
guess they I guess today is just not my
luck it's not my
day and then he gets up and turns around
and goes to leave tips the lady a chunk
and the lady's like goddamn he's tipping
nice he lost close to a million dollars
and he's tipping nice and then he says
after he's turned around he says you
know what we just play one more time and
he [ __ ] cashes some chips
plays a bigger bet than he's ever played
more than he lost and then he gets 13
and the lady has is showing and showing
a [ __ ] face card and he and she says
you want to hit and he says you know
what the way I've been playing is so
[ __ ] up I might as well play against
the rules now I'm gonna stay and
everyone goes deep and they say you
really shouldn't and jeremy renner says
I got this and then she says okay and
then she flips the card over and it's a
six and then everyone goes huh and she
has to hit and she flips a car over and
it's another face car and you're a face
card and Gemma Renner says hey I'd like
that massage and then he [ __ ] walks
away with his chips and he would comes
out of [ __ ] winner
bro and you notice as he's walking into
the elevator nobody noticed until the
last moment that his dick was out the
whole time do you understand that's the
[ __ ] my dream world not for me to do
it I want jeremy renner to do it and I
want to see it I'd [ __ ] start beating
the [ __ ] at everyone if I saw that out
of respect and I'd be punching this [ __ ]
everybody and people to be like dad what
are you doing I'd be like just in case
you murder doesn't like any of these
guys I got em all [ __ ] yeah dude that's
life that's life in my head uh anyway
man manscaped support for
congratulations comes from manscaped
who is number one in men's below the
belt roaming one guess manscaped I won I
got it right landscape two offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels positions when your family
jewels I did it didn't make my balls at
all so that's cool
and I got real big balls so a lot to
Nick but I didn't do it
I used it it's got a it's it's really
safe you know when you do it and you use
the one on your face even though you
don't do you think I don't to tell
anybody and you know you do it in your
balls and then you make them bleed a
little bit what manscape got it all
covered man manscape has redesigned the
electric trimmer their lawnmower 2.0 has
proprietary skin safe technology so this
trimmer won't nikkor snag and knots the
accident sort of thing of the past just
get a man scape manscape also has the
crop preserver and anti chafing ball
deodorant and moisturizer you already
put children on your armpits weighing up
on and gonna on the smelliest part of
your body be balls uh always use the
right tools for the job obviously your
balls will thank you if your balls had a
mouth they'd be like thanks get 20% off
free shipping and a free travel bag with
the code congrats at manscape comm
that's 20% off with free shipping and a
free travel bag at manscape calm and use
code Congrats
to movement white male priviledge
hipsters
by the way this will be my last show
ever
hey guys one of the funniest comedians
around and I mean this one of my top
favorite comedians if not my favorite
comedian doing it today he could be and
honestly just one of my all-around
favorite people love the guys always all
smiles he's such a great guy check out
bill burrs new special paper tiger only
on netflix September 10th
that's paper tiger and congrats to bill
on his new special where you can go
check it out
I hope you enjoyed as much as I will
congratulations is brought to you by
cash app the official app of the log
cabin um so yeah I was with my parents I
was at the whole fam last night and I'm
just gonna come out and say it and then
I'll tell this story my mom thinks that
my dog that their dog Lenny has been but
[ __ ] by a guy and yeah so that's a
real thing that a 70 year old woman
thinks my mom thinks her dog has been
but [ __ ] by a human guy so that and
now the interesting thing about that is
it didn't happen okay I swear to god
this happened years ago but we're used
to it dude my mom is a conspiracy
theorist okay that's what it is she's a
[ __ ] conspiracy theorist but only
about things like a human but [ __ ] her
dog dude first of all they found the dog
my uncle found the dog attached to a
tree and it was all muddy and [ __ ]
and he basically saved the dog and then
he couldn't have the dog cuz there Eddie
had too many dogs and then they gave it
to my mom and dad the dog's name is
Lenny and the interesting thing about
Lenny is he's never been but [ __ ] by a
human now my mom used to tell any and
whenever you got in your pet near his
but Lenny would be like her and because
of that
[Music]
my mom thinks Lenny was but [ __ ] by a
guy okay I mean dude when she said it I
had to go to the doctor to get my jaw
wired back onto my face cuz it hit the
floor dude we were petting
we're petting her and somebody said why
does Lenny always do that and mama says
well you know I mean I think that he got
butt [ __ ] by a guy I think I think so
no she said I think so I think somebody
butt [ __ ] him like his previous owner
that's what she said
my my mom's 70 a few years ago when she
was in her late 60's she says well I
think he got butt-fucked by one of his
previous owners or something like that
because when you pet near his butt he
growled
my brother and I looked at each other
for a week and a half just standing
there I were like mom the dog didn't get
butt-fucked by a guy you know and she
was like well and then sit and then
yesterday we brought it up but she was
like I mean I don't you know she tried
to backtrack but she really fix it right
I don't think I said that I don't think
I it was like Trump you know I didn't
say that exactly at is that somebody
thinking sort of and we're like okay you
said it he said it all so imagine being
butt-fucked by an owner and then your
previous owner went to go pet your butt
and you just growled you kidding me
you'd run away dude that was the
funniest [ __ ] thing man my mom is
crazy like she calls me [ __ ] cranks
for no reason she calls my brother
Maffei and me cranks my name is Chris
dude she named me that my name my
brother's name is Matthew she calls him
a fee says hate cranks hey Murphy Lenny
got bought [ __ ]
also she said butt [ __ ] oh man what if
he did and then he's like she's the only
one that knows um
yeah dude so funny talk about no dance
Lenny took a dent in his butt because
you're the star of the show
learning a buff ah
[Applause]
um anyway what else did I have I had
some oh dude this made me laugh that
there's a [ __ ] look I'm surprised it
took them this long to do this but it
did Apple is coming out with an Apple
card of because of course it is to
understand the only thing more of course
it is is that my mom thinking looks
things Elena got [ __ ] by his previous
owner okay Apple card is coming out
Apple is coming out with a card okay
first of all Apple don't come up with a
card but it did naturally and everyone's
gonna buy it why because Apple created
something that we all need which is like
the number-one rule in business and now
we can't live without it
so I was reading about this because I'm
really smart and I like to [ __ ] come
I like to I'll catch up on everything
that's been going on in the world and
I'm very very cultural and Apple card
does the new Apple card deliver them
where's the there was okay you can't
we're here here's what they said about
it you know I'm talking about right
Apple wants warns not to keep its credit
card by leather or denim or loose change
okay okay the only thing is that's where
everything in your pocket goes and also
your pocket that's made of denim and
also things you keep your credit card in
like [ __ ] wallets those are leather
so what
so I guess Apple what I'm asking is in a
very specific sense and a very specific
sensible question Apple what the [ __ ]
chew
doing what do you you know why you know
why cuz they're coming out with [ __ ]
Apple pants that's why and they're gonna
be wooden or like some [ __ ] titanium
[ __ ]
maybe I'll plug your credit card in your
pants and then you know there's you
don't need loose change he's got a
credit card and you don't need a leather
because we have the Apple wallet that's
also [ __ ] titanium and pretty soon
we're just gonna all be [ __ ] robots
hello I'd like to pay with my Apple card
hello I would like to pay with my Apple
card hello where do I insert my eppela
card you don't have to you can just
stand near the [ __ ] cash register
oops
George or Bing thanks that was 350 no
thank you
um yeah that's just changing the game
dude don't get this [ __ ] Apple card
because then you got to get new pants
I'm trying to get you know I'm gonna
[ __ ] that I'm gonna get straw pants and
anytime someone says what's up with your
stupid pants I'm gonna say bro you don't
know the future I'm trying to use my
[ __ ] Apple card I'm not that's like
when they say don't have your hotel keys
near other [ __ ] like hotel hey hotels
figured the [ __ ] out yeah well you're
not gonna want to put your [ __ ] thing
near your cell phone cuz demand ties is
that it no you don't make me do extra
work okay I'm paying you $350 a night to
[ __ ] sleep activate your card wake
iPhone up and when's this come out by
the way soon right probably I'm gonna
get it I'm gonna be so pissed what it
doesn't work I've had [ __ ] for for
your air pods for ear air pods whatever
the [ __ ] they're called for air pods so
dad before report your ear pods you got
your ear ear pods kids let's go get your
ear pods and I got four of them and I
lost all four and that's all good
that's it I said it to Rogan I was like
hey man I lost like four Perry's like me
too but it's worth it I was like okay I
guess that's the end of that
conversation
am I gonna talk to [ __ ] Joe Rogan
about earpods you know uh so yeah you
know but this Apple card made me laugh I
put a tweet up that by but I had burlap
pants I found a picture with burlap
pants and I wrote hello I'd like to pay
with my Apple card and it [ __ ] went
off the chain cuz daddy's Twitter game
has been on fire lately for real I must
have a million and when I do that's it
when I have a million Twitter followers
[Music]
um yeah so Lenny got but [ __ ] all good
I got a cameo from exhibit do you know
who X to the Z is you do if you're over
35 sup Chris I'm here to pimp your
podcast ad game it's mr. X to the Z
exhibit I need you to let me eat sponsor
break to add reads per break so your
listeners don't skip through them all
all right what's the difference between
me and you about 5 Brinks trucks 3m hits
and the log cabin to whatever that means
these seems like a nice guy there what's
3 M hits three million hits no that's
weird
that guy always [ __ ] what's the
difference between you what's the
difference between starts at the penis
that [ __ ] line dude what's the
difference between us it starts with the
penis when I say I don't give a [ __ ] I
really mean it um so yeah uh cuz you're
the star of the show
Brown that's his voice doing that - did
you guys see the influencer about the
[ __ ] that pretended she got in a
motorcycle accident and then shot it
either way it's bad either way it's bad
don't go my [ __ ] cousin one time said
he he didn't want to go to college and
they obviously had been brewing with
between him and his dad and my uncle
said to him right when he said he'd cut
him off said don't go don't go don't go
Nick don't go and it was like so mad you
know anyway he went so yeah an
influencer is defending her decision to
post a photo shoot of her motorcycle
accident on Instagram hey bye dude
bye bye if I was in an airplane and I
was going to do a [ __ ] skydive and I
wasn't sure and I was nervous and then
somebody just pulled that up and showed
it to me I jump out then I got [ __ ]
who cares if it doesn't open
she also denied to me that smart water
featured in one of the festival that the
smart water featured in one of the
professional photos she's a brand
endorsement I who gives a [ __ ] dude
me so she put this was on BuzzFeed I
mean a lot of people picked it up I
tweeted about it I said how influencers
[ __ ] suck dude just get a job man no
you know what don't get a job don't get
a job develop actually develop period
get up get up a [ __ ] skill develop a
skill dude don't just sit near a [ __ ]
you know umbrella and then and then have
some dude take a bitch-ass picture you
see these dudes take the pictures all
[ __ ] squat it out with their with
their hands like all [ __ ] this is me
this is what this girl says tiffer le or
something this is me and my bike about
an hour before I got into an accident if
you watch my story Sunday you know all
about it but if you didn't here's the
scary magical
series of events a few of us wrote down
the leapers Fork Saturday to explore and
take pictures yeah you didn't go to
explore you went to go take pictures my
sweet friend
yada-yada was shooting and my other
sweet friend yada yada was riding while
a friend of Lindsay's drove the Jeep
alright dude you know we don't need all
this [ __ ] okay cool
what is this the [ __ ] describing it
back into the left back into the left
this is like the [ __ ] JFK trial so
then she was driving and then and then
the other sweet friend was riding and
then while Lindsey drove the jury Jeep
we don't give a [ __ ] we played around
for a couple hours before heading back
up to Nashville course course they were
going back to Nashville and around 7:30
and on a secluded two-lane stretch I
misjudged a curve took it too fast and
my bike went off the road it slid
through the grass and I hit the pavement
I had my helmet on so my head was fine
but I Yatta Yatta [ __ ] farted
it took a and then and the whole time I
was listening to [ __ ] main attraction
that's what she said exactly word for
word
and so this was so she did the thing
made the tweet made the Instagram and
then like they got pictures of her like
in pain on the ground and this
photographer was just taking pictures of
it and then [ __ ] posted it and
filtered it out and it all fits the
aesthetic on her Instagram page cabe Oh
oops
you did the wrong thing babe eh dude
this is just so s bad guess if she says
the word event adventure in the [ __ ]
caption - everything's a goddamn
adventure dude - these chicks everything
is a goddamn adventure they could
[ __ ] lay in bed and be like today I
[ __ ] just didn't I just did ventured
with my pillow I just had ventured
watching the hostel the hostel trilogy
ooh scary
I need to go on
an adventure like that only without the
rape and [ __ ] getting killed lol my
friend was there to take pictures this
is these aesthetics to that they have
are all like [ __ ] always like brown
and tan these chicks it's crazy dude
it's so crazy to me the world and that's
it
how many what
I'll follow up post she's sitting on her
bike cool all [ __ ] all done out and
that smart water was all [ __ ] placed
and not earlier one two this is a
follow-up post cool I've been figuring
out how to respond to everything that's
unfolded recently regarding the post I
shared two weeks ago about my moto
accident at shortened it I won't get
into the post here see my moto accident
story for highlighter for all the
details s still promoting her accident
didn't learn all good keeps touching the
hot stove but I want to talk about the
reactions I've been getting to the
article at BuzzFeed news posted
sensationalizing what I went through
that day and making a mockery of the
post I shared oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
dude I don't say this word a lot but
sweetheart you were the one making a
mockery of your [ __ ] accident when
you put gradient on it is that the right
way to say that who gives a [ __ ] when
you when you adjusted the gradient is
that how I say I don't know when you
opened the aperture know nothing about
it I've been accused of state as a
result I've been accused of staging the
accident to get attention do you know
why equ were accused you know why you're
accused of that Oh J using it as a
product placement opportunity with a
water company I also don't give that's
that part I don't give a flying [ __ ]
about I don't care about that we're all
suckers and Cudas for drinking the [ __ ]
anyway who cares if they post it with in
it with a fake I don't give a [ __ ] some
water yum-yum-yum-yum I drink it give me
Liam use that for a [ __ ] smart water
ad smart water I drink it yum yum yummy
Liam I don't give a [ __ ] she crashed and
put his smart water on the photo I don't
give a [ __ ] I'll take a shower in it
give me more put it up above my [ __ ]
I'll take an outdoor shower with it
yum-yum-yum-yum-yum I'll open up my
[ __ ] mouth and just drink it while I
wash my [ __ ] armpits with it
[Music]
I've been [ __ ] so using his efficient
water company and other things I can't
even wrap my head around I will we
wrapped our heads around it for you I've
been sharing real-life stories here
since I started my account I've opened
up about miscarriage divorce anxiety
losing my partner in a motor accident
three years ago and navigating grief
that followed I've chosen to use
Instagram as a tool for healing and
connecting with other humans who may be
going through similar things so we can
do it together and it's been beautiful
when I work with brands they're ones I
personally enjoy and I disclose every
single sponsorship accusing someone of
faking or exploiting the accidents
extremely serious because of because
what if you're wrong I really it really
happened to me and I was scared I really
was injured and I had to recover I was
in chocolate on the side of the road
having flashbacks when I lost someone
very important to me friends were on my
side look I don't even give a [ __ ] if
the [ __ ] really happened and the [ __ ]
really happened what's what's the
difference between us it starts with the
penis but if the [ __ ] really happened
that's fine the problem I don't have the
problem I I have isn't with the fact
that I think it's a fake motorcycle
accident as a matter of fact that's bad
that's better than falling on the ground
in a real way scraping the [ __ ] out of
your tattooed shoulder and asking your
friend to take photos about it because
that's the way that we know he got
mental problem unny
but you falling down hurting yourself
having flashbacks from losing your
partner to the same
accident and asking your friends to take
gradient shots means you got mental
problems are dented dude that's the
hugest problem of it all oh [ __ ] I
crashed get out your camera that's not a
sentence that you say why are you acting
like the not problem is the problem the
only problem is the real problem dude I
want to have a game show called the real
problem people come up and be like so hi
I'm Nancy and I own an accounting firm
and now I want to tell you my problem oh
yeah
well Nancy what's your problem well the
problem is everyone thinks that I faked
a motorcycle accident to put on
Instagram so I could do a deal with
SmartWater
ona's law will be right after these
messages
to decide what the real problem is
everybody went back it's fine out the
real problem Nancy now here before the
commercial break she said that there was
a problem because we thought it was a
brand and fuck'em SmartWater but what
what's the real power well I'll tell you
what the real problem is her [ __ ]
brains all dented up we have a new
jeremy renner hey Jemma render your
success factor and you got 400 [ __ ]
quadrillion dollars what's the deal
you're an Avenger and you're also in
good movies like the [ __ ] hurt rocker
so what's going on man you want to do
music well yeah I always loved music and
a you know the real problem is never got
a chance to do it and now that I'm
[ __ ] 45 I got a chance to do it
oh cool we'll be right back after these
[ __ ] messages psych we're back it out
the real problem is you just want to be
more famous
[Music]
with Christmas anyway do it I'm the
biggest [ __ ] jeremy renner fan only
now now now dude 4.3 million views
how much epicness do you want in this
video
jeremy renner yes [ __ ]
hey jeremy renner you playing poker how
relaxed do you want to be with this
massage jeremy renner yes i guess that's
good for that man that was a really fun
episode dude and just remember if you
see my mom asked her how that he's doing
cuz you know it was butt [ __ ] by a
human so download the download the cash
app for free on the App Store or Google
Play market that's a really good idea to
do that it's also a really good idea
what you're doing that and download and
post mates to download the crystally app
you download the Chris D'Elia app and
you [ __ ] get to listen to the first 12
13 minutes just today first you know ten
minutes or so live before anyone else I
need to see me do it well I support the
show by buying merch we got everything's
restocked at the Chris D'Elia store the
Christopher everything's restocked so go
get it now people always like my size is
sold out it's not sold out now go now
subscribe to the YouTube channel rate
and review it really helps us on iTunes
and tweet me by using the handler
congratulate spot it doesn't matter I
don't [ __ ] look at it and I'll look
at it if I want to maybe some days I do
some days I don't so it's all good I do
it I want because I'm trying to live
that hedonistic less out and I try to
don't do whatever I [ __ ] don't want
to do and that's what we should do now
let me just [ __ ] the clothes out by
saying this too I'm a happy guy and
let's just be nice to everybody this
week
no sideways [ __ ] no [ __ ]
backhanded compliments it's a deeper and
we're just gonna hang out we're gonna
have a good time we're gonna tell for
compliments we're gonna do [ __ ] we're
gonna call people out for their [ __ ]
but we're not gonna do it in a shitty
way we're gonna do it in a loving way
because we love each other
that's why cuz we're all humans and
we're all the main attraction in our own
way isn't that right
jeremy renner play us out if we had
money to buy the song
and I had a good time dude you guys are
great I'm gonna be in Santa Barbara
Riverside San Diego doesn't matter gonna
sell out anyway even though I [ __ ]
even if I don't say it cuz it's all good
thanks for listening my babies and
remember we can't all be the [ __ ]
have a good one
[Music]